listening comprehension as i've said
before is the core skill
that leads us to speaking better leads
us to reading better leads us to
better a better sense of the language hi
there steve coffin here and today i want
to talk about listening the most
powerful activity in language learning
remember if you enjoy my videos please
subscribe click on the bell for
notifications if you follow me on a
podcast service please leave a comment
so i've spoken a lot a lot about
listening
but today i was reminded of how
tremendously powerful a learning
activity it is
i had to spend much of the day
cleaning up around the house
donating some books and other material
to the thrift store getting rid of a lot
of garbage so i had to go to the
recycling depot
so there was a good an hour and a half
two hours between working and driving
and i listened to my persian podcast
b-plus podcast
now
first of all what's powerful is that i'm
able to use all this time time that
would otherwise be dead time
second of all
uh this b plus podcast uh this ali
bandari i think it is he talks about a
variety of different subjects what's of
interest to me is the history of iran so
he talks about the safavi
dynasty he talks about different
kings shah of the safavi dynasty
smiles
abbas and so forth
and of course i have heard some of this
stuff before but i get it again in a
slightly different context so i'm
learning
not deliberately learning not taking
notes but gradually things are becoming
clearer to me through listening
and i'm i'm reminded of the fact that
throughout history for most of recorded
history we had no writing people
couldn't read like yes the first and one
of the earliest in fact
examples of writing is is this writing
on these clay cylinders and in fact
uh darius's famous
kind of the one of the first
written documents about human rights was
was written in cuneiform script
on these clay cylinders
and but if we go through history you
know again going back to that time you
know the legend of gil gilgamesh or
the odyssey or or the the iliad or
uh in in south and southeast asia the
ramayana
story stories from china from elsewhere
people have had stories and people
listened it's just that they didn't have
mp3 players
and they listened more than once
and we all have this
as children we had our favorite stories
and these
in order for the the iliad or the
ramayana or any of these famous stories
to be passed on from generation to
generation
people told these stories more than once
and they were favorite stories and
people were happy to listen to them over
and over again and they enjoyed
different aspects of the story
every time they listened and similarly
you know as i'm listening as i said in
one of my previous videos i don't
deliberately try to understand and of
course i lose focus from time to time
and i'm sure that
children sitting around the campfire
listening to a story every so often they
you know look somewhere else and they
lose focus and then they come back to it
it doesn't matter but
it's such a powerful
means of bringing knowledge into your
brain
and it's it it you know evokes
the subject in a way that video can't do
i remember when i uh
i got these uh storytellers chinese
storytellers telling the romance of the
three kingdoms
and
the man's voice and the way he conjured
up horses and dust i could almost smell
the dust and see the action because it
was all words
and when i got to see a video of the
same story
it was a pale
uh version of the same far less
left to the imagination
obviously fewer words so so this
listening is so powerful uh you'll see
on my uh shot of my screen at link that
i've been you know listening to these
stud stories and studying the text so
that i understand them a bit better each
time
uh but i've never looked and these are
videos these are youtube videos and i'm
sure he shows a lot of stuff and
pictures of these uh persian kings and
whatever but
i just listen i just listen and read
and so i have an image incomplete
somewhat imperfect it doesn't matter my
knowledge is accumulating every time i
listen i i gather a few more words i get
a different sense of these kings and
their time and isfahan and different
aspects of the history the culture the
geography of iran and some words and
it's all gradually accumulating without
any deliberate effort on my on my part
but it's it's it's accumulating it's
accumulating like like uh
you know i've often used the image in
language learning of this if you start
rolling a snowball down a hill it'll
gradually pick up more and more snow and
and that's how it is and yet it's so
portable it's so easy to do if i had to
watch his videos i would have to sit
down and watch them
uh and i'm gonna do a video about
reading which is powerful in its own way
because it's a lovely environment to get
into just you know you and the text
without the sound without the audio just
you and the text
that's also powerful but reading is
something that has come relatively
lately to humans and and in particular
the vast majority of humans didn't read
until about the 15th 16th 17th 18th
century and so they relied on the spoken
word they relied on familiar stories
told over and over again
as a means of acquiring information as a
means of entertainment and we now can
use that same
the wonder of storytelling as a means of
acquiring knowledge as a means of
acquiring
language as a form of entertainment
and and of course the means of
delivering this have just proliferated
so we have podcasts and we have you know
audiobooks and different services
podcast services uh
audiobook services
and so this this rich world where
you know it used to be they would have
to
maybe sit in a
in a room somewhere or sit outside
underneath the trees to listen to the
storyteller spin his or her tail
very often a story that we were familiar
with
in the olden days and now we just carry
that with us i mean how many stories can
i keep in how many different languages
just in my little iphone and i can
listen to whichever one i want to listen
to i can even shuffle them and listen to
them in different orders i can go to
different languages
all of those things are now available to
us
and i think so listening
is
not only a very effective way of
learning
listening comprehension as i've said
before is the core skill
that leads us to speaking better leads
us to reading better leads us to
better a better sense of the language
but it is also a major form of
entertainment it's a major form of
enjoying the language particularly when
we don't have the opportunity to be
surrounded by people speaking the
language
there are so many means today
through technology whereby we can access
the language and enjoyment and knowledge
through listening and so and another
thing about listening to is it's kind of
easy to do so it gets you going
as i've said before very often the main
thing is to get started so even in terms
of a day
you know today i had to do some chores
around the house but i start listening
now because i've been listening
and not understanding a fair amount of
it i am now my my curiosity is piqued it
triggers my reading and it just keeps me
going down the path of learning the
language so i just wanted again i wanted
to touch on this the importance of
listening as the easiest thing you can
do in order to create the time and push
yourself forward in your language
learning and i'll leave you a couple of
videos about listening that i've done in
the past and hopefully again i don't
contradict myself thank you for
listening bye for now